- [Narrator] This USCD-TV
program is presented by
University of California television.
Like what you learned?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(classical piano music)
- [Carta Narrator] We
are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
- When we talk about medicine,
I think it's quite important
to think about what is medicine?
Right, it is the study
and intervention of human
physiological systems,
and physical systems,
and psychiatric systems.
When they are dis-regulated.
To attempt to correct what
is going on, to improve
human health and in order to do that,
we have to have a deep
understanding of not only
the dysfunction of these systems,
but how they function
when doing healthy things
within our bodies.
And so, to me, the term
medicine really means
applied human biology.
And as every biologist knows,
we have a favorite quote,
which is that nothing
in biology makes sense,
except in the light of evolution.
And this means that to understand
the organizing principles
of any organism,
biologically on this planet,
we need to understand
its evolutionary history.
And the series of selected
pressures that have shaped
that organism to function the way it does
in the particular context
in which it finds itself.
And, as an anthropologist,
who studies maternal health
and infant development, I
have a particularly favorite
adaptation that I care about.
And it is the synthesis of
milk from mammary glands,
which is the defining
characteristic of our
mammalian class.
It's as Barbara pointed
out, why mammals are at risk
of breast cancer, because
we have mammary glands.
And mother's milk, initially
a random mutation for
minor secretion that perhaps
hydrated young or provided
rudimentary immunofactors,
have been shaped by hundreds
of millions of years of
evolution and natural selection,
to become increasingly complex.
Such that it provides
nourishment for young,
it provides comprehensive
immune protection
for the pathogens babies
are likely to encounter.
And it also provides bio-active
hormones from maternal
circulation that cross over
into the infant and influence
infant physiological regulation.
It is due to this complex
bio-fluid that is food,
medicine and signal that has
led every major governmental
and non-governmental organization
to recognize mother's milk
as both liquid gold and
breastfeeding as the gold standard
of early life input from the mother.
However, because of the
ubiquity of milk within
our environment, and its
seeming replication in the form
of artificial breast milk
that you can buy at the store,
we have come to take milk for granted,
and think of it as a
standardized, systematized,
simple kind of thing.
And we've lost sight of
the things that make it
incredibly complex and special.
And it's that we have
not actually identified
what are liquid gold standards.
We do not have a systematic
understanding of milk.
How it varies, what that
variance does when ingested
by the infant, and these are
fundamental things we need
to uncover in order to
better manage infant health
within the neonatal intensive care unit.
And better target our
public health intervention.
And so, I think an evolutionary
perspective is incredibly
important in order to both
design and effectively target
research studies, but also to
help inform our understanding
of this dynamic system.
Because lactation is a
complex adaptive system
in which natural selection
has shaped mothers' physiology
and their mammary glands to
synthesize milk in complex ways.
And there's a fundamental
thing that I think is very
challenging when we're thinking
about managing the health
of a mother and an infant.
Because we think about, how
do we optimize that infant's
outcome in that particular time and place?
For the challenge that infant is handling.
Or trying to handle.
And this is challenging
because natural selection
has not shaped mothers to
optimize the outcome of
a particular infant.
Natural selection has
shaped mothers' physiology
to allocate investment
in young across an entire
reproductive career.
To maximize her reproductive
success across her
reproductive life span.
And because of this, we see
that there are going to be
a number of trade-offs
in how she allocates
resources between her
own body and how she's
nourishing her infant.
Just like I can only spend a dollar once,
an organism can only burn a calorie once.
And if that calorie's
burned on immune function,
it's not available to allocate
toward infant development.
And we see the signature
of these trade-offs
broadly in how mothers
are synthesizing milk.
But this evolutionary
life history perspective
has not been systematically
integrated into medical
approaches within infant care management.
The important thing there is
that food, medicine, and signal
of milk is going to
vary across all mothers.
The presence and abundance
of a particular milk
bio-active is not
standardized, and in fact,
the signature in milk across
each individual mother
is going to be different.
When we look at milk
synthesis, across every single
potential scale of consideration,
we find that milk varies.
It varies across species.
It varies across
populations within species.
Across individuals within
populations, within
individual across lactations,
within individuals within a
lactation, and we can actually
see the synthesis of milk
and composition of a
particular bio-active shift
from hour to hour throughout the day.
And so, to kind of think
about, what are the signatures
that we see in the milk
a mother synthesizes?
So, Dr Elizabeth Quinn has
shown that just the fat content
in milk, you can go to the
store and it's processed
and you can get it at
three percent, two percent,
one percent, or where the
fat's entirely removed.
But across human
populations, the mean value
of the fat content in their
milk is substantially variable.
We see gradients between
rural and urban communities
in things like, their
minerals, fatty acids, hormones
and sugars within milk.
We see the signature of
cultural ecology in the form
of subsistence patterns in their milk.
This is shown for fatty
acids, immunofactors, sugars,
and minerals.
Melanie Martin now at
Yale University has shown
that among forager
horticulturalists in the Amazon
that the Omega-3 fatty acid
concentration in their milk
is not only higher than
that which is found
in the breast milk of women
living in the Ohio River Valley,
but their ratio of Omega-3s to Omega-6s is
closer to what we consider
to be the most healthy
for infants.
Across individuals, when
we look at dairy cows
as a model for lactation
biology, humans and monkeys
as another model for human bio-medicine,
we find that maternal
characteristics are going to
leave their signature in milk.
Mothers who have better body conditions,
lower parasite loads, and
greater social capital
or access to resources, are
going to synthesize milk
in different ways than mothers
who are more constrained.
We see this in the volume of
milk that they're producing,
fat concentration and hormonal signals.
Similarly across these same species,
we find that the infants'
characteristics are also
implicated in the variation
of milk that mothers
are synthesizing.
So, the age of the infant
at birth in terms of
gestational age, the infant's
sex, whether it's male
or female, and whether
or not the infant is sick
are all implicated in
different aspects of milk
composition and production.
This differentiated
biological recipe in milk
has been found broadly
across a number of different
mammal species and it's
important to understand
that this does not
necessarily mean that mothers
are making better or worse milk
for either sons or daughters.
But where sons and daughters
have different developmental
priorities, different
developmental trajectories,
we can expect that the
milk that mothers use
to nourish them is going
to influence aspects
of those developmental trajectories.
When we go to the grocery store,
or the pharmacy, there's
different deodorant for
men and women, right?
But when we go into the
infant formula section,
in the grocery store,
it's one size fits all.
And we do not yet have enough
information scientifically
to say that's not best practices.
We haven't allocated the
research effort to understanding,
could we get better infant
developmental outcomes
if we had more tailored milk for them?
For infants who don't have
access to breast milk,
for whatever reason.
Across time, we see that mothers
early in their reproductive
career, dairy cows, seals,
and monkeys I work with,
that adolescent mothers
make different milk
than mature mothers,
that across parities,
mothers make different milks.
This can be in the nutritional components,
as well as the hormonal
components of their milk.
And the signatures that
this may leave in infant
development are still poorly understood.
So lactation is an adaptive
contingency system,
in which mothers that have
more access to resources
are able to up-regulate
aspects of milk synthesis
or mothers that are
constrained down-regulate
milk synthesis to protect
their condition for
future reproduction,
and this is shown both
through the milk that they're synthesizing
and their behavioral
dynamic with their infant.
And this is a function
of maternal resources
and their allocations among
different trade off priorities.
An adolescent thirteen
year old human mother
is going to be constrained in her capacity
to synthesize milk, so that
means that clinical support
for that mother-infant dyad
is going to have to take
into consideration the
cascading trade off allocations
between her condition and
the condition of her infant.
And this is important
because where milk production
is constrained, where milk
production is insufficient,
we see impacts on infant development.
So milk composition and
milk volume is implicated
in different growth,
their immune functions,
how microbes colonize
their intestinal tract,
their cognition and their behavior.
We see this in animal
model systems in a variety
of different human settings.
And this is quite important
because in the media,
we're seeing a lot of
pushback on the specialness
of breast milk, or the
importance of breast milk.
Because it's really
centered around a narrative
of best case scenario.
For full term infants,
that are born healthy,
and raised in incredibly protected
and buffered environments
the effect size that's
transferred by being breastfed
or formula fed is going
to be fairly moderate.
But when we anchor the
narrative to those best case
scenarios, we lose sight
of many situations in which
the consequences can be quite a bit dire.
So if we think about the
premature infant born
in the less than 39 weeks,
that ends up in the NICU,
you know, very very young
infants, 25, 27, 29 weeks of age
that spend a substantial
amount of time in the neonatal
intensive care unit, breast
milk or bio-active features
of breast milk can be absolutely
critical for their health.
If we think of children
growing up in spaces with
substantial infectious disease risk,
then the immunofactors that
are present in breast milk
and not found in other alternatives,
are going to be very important.
In settings in which
there is substantial risk
of development of
allergies or other kinds of
autoimmune kinds of
challenges, then breast milk
may be a buffer to that.
And even when we think about
that best case scenario,
where individuals are most buffered,
and the effect sizes
are the most moderate,
when we scale those up
across a population,
the health consequences add up.
And the health care dollar
costs add up substantially.
So we need to think about not
just the best case scenario,
not just one child and her options,
but at a public health,
population level as well.
So this is a complex adaptive system,
and we can use that
understanding of these systems
and how they've been
shaped by natural selection
to identify particular
strategies and targets
for intervention.
So some aspects of milk
synthesis are going to be
quite flexible, some are going
to represent constraints,
and some are going to
be fixed as a function
of genotype or other types of variables.
And these situations where
these represent trade-offs
of the mother, we can
use public interventions,
access to resources, social
justice and public health
interventions like the WIC program to help
improve the resources so
mothers are not trading off
to the same extent as
they are when they have
fewer resources.
When the constraints become more fixed,
when there isn't a capacity
to influence mothers,
to up-regulate their milk synthesis,
or shift their milk composition,
then we have opportunities
in which evolutionary
insights can yield
important advantages to how
we approach milk management.
So right now we see that
20 million infants are born
premature across the globe each year.
The vast majority of these are happening
in the global South.
And these infants are administered milk
as a clinical intervention,
so this is either
donor milk, formula, or
other kinds of modified
milk products, which
have their own bioethical
considerations.
Right now, these milks
represent mean values
as though we know the gold standard.
And this is an erasing of
a lot of the individual
or more specialized,
tailored features of milk.
And these products and
interventions are based off of
mean values among what would we call,
or what Joe Henrich would
coin, weird populations.
Westernized, educated,
industrialized, rich,
democratic populations, okay?
Weird, they're weird.
And they do not necessarily
reflect ancestral conditions.
Or the diversity of milks
that mothers are making,
but if we make this our gold standard,
and it's not actually
the best target for us
to replicate and match,
then we're going down
a sub-optimal pathway.
So we can think about,
what do we know about milk?
What has already been found
out, and can we from there
design clinical trials
and other kinds of studies
to see if there is
added-value space within
clinical care.
So right now in the
NICU, some form of milk
is being provided.
Can we do better if we
start thinking in terms
of precision milk,
along with other aspects
of precision medicine?
So can we do better if we match milk
for the, whether the child or
baby is a son or a daughter?
Can we do better if we give
morning milk in the morning
and night milk at night?
Adults and children have
circadian rhythms in which
our glucocorticoids are
higher in the morning
and lower in the afternoon and evening
and while we sleep.
Babies don't have a circadian rhythm.
They get information
about a circadian rhythm
through their mother's milk.
So what happens when we
provide day milk at night?
Does that excite the babies' systems?
This is an empirical
question for which we do not
have published information at this time.
For babies that get
milk could we do better
if we matched donors in a selective way?
That we add value by
taking milk from particular
life history stages or mothers
of particular genotypes
in the donor options?
It's an empirical question.
We don't yet know.
The FUT2 genotype influences what sugars
and whether or not they're fucosselated,
are present in milk,
and these are important for influencing
the microbial colonization
of the infant's gut.
Can we target pooling milk across mothers
to create a super milk that's going to be
quite important for
particularly vulnerable
or sick infants?
Can we mix glicands to maximize the health
of the microbial system
colonizing the infant's gut?
Can we provide particular
microbes to those infants?
Right now, all of the
milk processing techniques
in the neonatal intensive
care unit involve
neutralizing these components
of milk that we know
are potentially quite important.
And lastly, can we co-opt and bio-engineer
milk bio-actives from
other species that are
solving evolutionary problems that have
importance for infants in the NICU today?
So when you look at the
marsupials, kangaroos,
wallabies, they're born
at very, very early stages
of development.
They have very undeveloped lungs.
And there's milk
bio-actives within the milk
that their mothers
synthesize, that accelerate
the development of their
lungs specifically.
Could it be possible to
replicate or bio-engineer that
in ways that we can provide it
to these 25, 27, 29 week old
infants who are at huge
risk for pnuemonial disease
because their lungs are undeveloped?
And there are people in
Australia working on answering
that question right now.
They're using an evolutionary perspective
of how natural selection
has shaped adaptations
to solve problems that
have implications for
the unique challenges that humans face
in our particular cultural context.
And lastly, when most of
this has been talking about
donor milks and bioengineering.
But there are many infants
who do not have access to milk
for a variety of reasons.
There are metabolic disorders,
other kinds of illnesses in
which mothers are not able
to synthesize milk,
there's historical traumas
and cultural contexts
that make it very difficult.
There are infants who are
raised by wonderful families
that don't include a mom.
And these families rely in
very important ways on formula.
Artificial breast milk.
How do we make a better
artificial breast milk
that delivers more of the
important bio-actives in milk
to help enhance those
infants' development?
These are the kinds of things
we can take an evolutionary
perspective, apply it to a
variety of clinical and cultural
settings to improve human health.
And this is what it means to
be thinking evolutionarily
to approach medical condition
challenges of human infants.
Thank you.